Here we go.
We are recording. Welcome to another Zoom call.
We have a number of questions to get through and then we'll open it up for your chat. So let's get started.
First, some reminders. Remember that if you do have questions about something, always go to the website first.
And do a search in this little thing where the arrow is pointed to any page of the website. You can do that search like that. And you can see.
Ask a question. So.
And we may have made a blog post about it at some point of time. So if you have a question about different things like.
Does he has you ever talked and talked about, you know, whatever you could, you could at least get some ideas if we made a video if I've made a blog post or something like that that could be helpful for you.
All right, let's get to some questions. We are initiated a gradual deck of drawn decks of methods own weed. So this person who's writing this question is weeded off of anti inflammatory steroid.
What rife programs should we run for this? Well, there isn't any specific rife programs to help you weed off of something, but.
I understand the mechanism of action of the drug that you can try to do some rife programs that will help support what that drug was trying to do. In this case, this is an anti inflammatory.
So running some swelling programs, some anti employment. I think there's an inflammation program and a swelling program on the right. Those are two things that you could run.
If is can have some benefits for swelling and inflammation, but that's not the key component of the rife is swelling and inflammation. So there's some limitations to the rife. It's a tool you have to use it the right way.
It's not going to be a great tool for decreasing inflammation.
So this could we do to support this? Well, that's the next question. What else could you do? Well, opine anti inflammatory nutrients like curcumin, resveratrol, EGCG from green tea extract white willow bark, stingy dental.
Yeah, things like that.
Cercetin.
Even an acetyl cystine can help a little bit the vitamin.
The total the delta total tree dolls from vitamin E member vitamin E has four inner components and four outer components, the outer components are the to cough or all the inner components are the total tree dolls that delta.
The anti inflammatory and all can be anti inflammatory can reduce inflammation in.
In cytokine formation that can be helpful as well. So things like that.
Other tools that can be helpful to decrease inflammation coffee enemas can be very helpful to decrease inflammation anything that you can do to support parasympathetic function.
Let's move back to the blog post.
Let me pull it up real quick. The blog post new parasympathetic toad would be beneficial. So,
let me grab it.
If you just go again to that search bar and you search sympathetic or parasympathetic.
And you'll see, you'll see a blog post on sympathetic parasympathetic tone.
And it will be look like that at the top.
And that has a video to talk about different things that you could do to stimulate parasympathetics on that blog post.
Also you have two different PDFs that you could download one on reducing sympathetic tone, one on increasing parasympathetic tone. So I won't go into details on that. I've talked about that on a lot of the calls that you can watch that video.
You can do to decrease sympathetic and increase parasympathetics are going to be helpful to decrease inflammation.
We are running the 18 minute adrenal program one to three times a day.
That's good to that will help. So you want to decrease inflammation, you want to stimulate just a good balance of hormone function.
So the other thing you can think of is adaptogens.
So adaptogenic herbs.
And adaptogenic mushrooms can be very beneficial to.
Next, I was wondering about being able to have an evening drink with my wife. We used to have a drink together, which hasn't happened very often at all.
Vodka came up as a possibility. I think vodka's made for potatoes. Can you share any thoughts about that.
So alcohol and cancer. That's the real question. How much alcohol can a person drink?
Where it starts to become bad for them. Well, there's there's some it really partly it depends.
I don't know who was asked this question, but it depends on partly on what type of cancer you have. I mean, one.
Blanket answer would be you should stay away from alcohol completely.
And there are one of the reasons that you could arguments that you could make for that is that alcohol is going to tax your liver.
And if you don't have a better what type of cancer have you have if you're going to drink alcohol, you're going to take up a lot of side of growth, the P450 energy to get rid of the alcohol alcohol converts to an aldehyde.
And you have to you, it takes a lot of energy in your liver.
And you have to to deal with that. So is that a wise thing to do when you're dealing with a serious disease and you could argue that it's not necessarily wise thing to do, even if you're not dealing with serious disease.
Because that can end up being a factor and you getting a serious disease is the fact that you have taxed your liver. So you put stress on your liver, you took up energy from detox pathways that now you can't detox the
heavy metals that you were exposed to or the other toxins that you were exposed to and that settles in the cells and that's the cause of a future cancer.
Well, maybe you never would have had that settle in the cells you would have been able to detoxify it if you weren't taking up energy from these detox pathways to deal with alcohol that you're dealing with.
It's about a conversation is that for people who like alcohol, well, but that's the truth of it. It gets worse if you have any inflammation of the brain. So if you have had chemotherapy, so you already have some damage to microglial cells in the brain, then alcohol is an absolute no no.
And all the studies with microglial primate that's damaged to the to specific brain cells alcohol across the board was a major player and causing increase inflammation primed microglial cells.
It's just people that have any type of brain inflammation from either they did chemotherapy they had a brain to or they had concussions post concussive syndrome, even if you're 60 years older, you had concussions when you're a teenager, you really need to stay away from alcohol, just there's a lot of downsides. So it's like gosh, this is okay, he's really
busted my balloon here, but it's is there a balance in all of this then so I'm telling you all the negatives of alcohol, but is there a balance of this well, yeah, you have to find that balance, drinking one vodka tonic at night, I think is way out of balance.
So that's not to be a balance, if you're going to drink a couple of drinks of vodka a couple vodka tonics a month, maybe that would be a balance.
Well, how about wide, wide is different, wide is a lower alcohol content that you know 80 proof vodka, it's only 12 proof or whatever in wine, so it has a lower alcohol content. Well, that's true. So it is going to do last damage on your liver. So could you have a glass of white at night.
Maybe again, you're taking up energy from your liver detox pathway. So maybe I would say maybe a couple glasses of wine a week would be maximum.
And again, if you have any inflammation and any evidence of prime microglial cells, I would say that you can't do that at all.
And if you have questions about what I just said about prime microglial cells go to the website again in this section right here search for
um, um, neuroinflammation, I think it's under, I think that's what I have a video on prime microglial cells, what that is, and I think it's under neuroinflammation, and it's a 30 minute video, and it explains what I just said there in detail as far as anatomical physiological function of what's takes place in your brain.
And alcohol compounds that greatly. So I just made all enemies there, but sorry.
Next, how much of your foot should be underwater in the foot bath? Um, you want to get as much of your foot underwater. So how much water should you put in there you want to fill it up about, you know, so that it's a few inches from the top so that you could actually pick it up without spilling it while you're going to the sink.
So, but you want to get your foot in there so that you have enough surface area that is underwater that's getting benefit.
The next in my binder, it says can I eat various that I can eat various types of meat except poultry so that's just what tested for you so that how much meat is recommended. So, um,
Um, we typically don't recommend that you eat meat, unless you know that you do better. So let's say even if a person tests that we're testing forward, we're testing foods, we're testing for any foods that are driving the cancer or feeding the cancer.
So if, if, um, in this case, you could eat various types of meat except poultry, um, then, uh, you, uh, hold on, stop the video there.
So you can't eat poultry so that means you could eat red meat or you could eat fish is that mean you should or you have to know it doesn't it means that those things are not driving the cancer.
Some people do better, not eating any meat or hardly at all, they might eat it only eat it once a week. Some people feel horrible if they only eat meat once a week, they need to eat it every day. That has to do with your body type, how your matiety pathway, what matiety pathway, how well you're breaking down B12 components, how well you absorb B12, there's other things that are
that are in that mix, not just what's feeding the cancer. So everybody's different that way. So in your case, if it says that you could eat various types of meat except poultry, how much meat is recommended or not recommended how much meat it has to do with your energy level.
If you do really well, if you feel like your energy is really good at boy, I eat only fish, I haven't had any red meat and I haven't had any, um,
poor, um, and I only eat fish. Well, it's every couple weeks, my energy is up and pretty doing really good, then just stick to that.
So, um, but if you're there's other people that boy, if they don't eat some meat, a little bit every day that they're down in the dumps that they need to do that.
Everyone else says that animal protein feeds cancer. So I kind of address that when we're testing for, we're testing for what is fueling the cancer.
So no, this is a wrong statement. I don't care what everybody else says.
They might be right. I'm just saying my opinion is animal protein does not always feed cancer. We are meant to be um, divorce, um, and, but we don't want to be fueling the cancer.
So with some people we tested, they're not on any meat.
Um, and a lot of people that meat is not feeding their cancer, something else is feeding their cancer and they can't eat meat and they feel very horrible if they don't eat meat.
So, um, cancer is different with everybody and cancer's fuel source can change in a given person as well. So when we test you, this is why we should do follow up.
We can't eat pork or poultry.
Something like that. It can change your body. The cancer is trying to bite a fuel source all the time. So you have to be, um, fluid and moldable.
You can't get cancer because things can change.
Will you tip capsule. So you is a, um, is a evergreen shrub that grows in multiple different areas of climates.
And it is becoming a more popular nutritional, nutraceutical.
And it could be a good immune stimulant. So it's in the family of, um,
what's that other evergreen that is, um, I can't remember. I'll think of it in a minute, but um, it's becoming a more popular nutraceutical.
Um, I can't interfere with black sap. No, I, I have not heard that it interferes with black sap at all. So no, I would say you could take it right along with black sap. My doctor questions it's the use.
And we'll suppress my immune response. No, no, because it, because it actually is an immune stimulant. So I don't believe that's true at all. The blacks have needs the immune response to exteriorize the tumor. So no, you can, I, it's not an immune suppressant.
Um, and it's not, um, and it's not an oxidizing agent like Kibo is, um, it's not, it doesn't damage your immune cells. So you could do it at the same time.
What do you consider histamine foods? So this is a good question to go right back to the block here. So you go right back to the, um,
uh, search for histamine foods. I've written, um, six or seven articles on histamine foods.
And what are the things that you'll find is an article that says low histamine diet, the high histamine food list. So that gives you a list of all those foods in that histamine diet.
There's a whole 30 histamine food list in there too. Whatever you're trying to decrease histamines, which all of us probably should try to decrease histamines in our foods.
It's just that it's trying to decrease histamines. You cannot eliminate histamines in your food. It's impossible there. It's basically histamines are just about anything.
And if they're not in something, if you've put that thing in their refrigerator a couple days, they will be in, you know, if histamines in that thing.
It's not a matter of a limited histamine. It's just reducing the histamine, uh, load on your body histamine, um, builds up in the person's body.
And you have specific genes, which help digest histamines in your gut. Those are your DAO genes. And it's made by, uh, uh, that enzyme is made by the DIDO gene.
It's called the DAO enzyme. You also have that enzyme made by a different gene in the tissues, your HNMT gene, makes it in the tissues to decrease histamines in your tissues.
So decreasing histamines in your diet is to try to take away, take down the histamine load, histamine is an inflammatory molecule.
It's taking down that histamine in an inflammation in the gut, and it could be very helpful.
Most people probably eat too many histamines because of damage guts. We have, even if you have very little defects on your DAO genes, you probably don't, um, break down histamines as well because of the damage of everybody's guts because of GMO foods, especially.
Um, and, um, so reducing your histamine load would be good for everyone.
Um, one could make an argument about, but look, you'll see that whole histamine diet of that.
Also, if you were told to go on a low histamine diet, your liaison probably sent you that whole 30 diet already. So look at your email box as well.
Can you talk about proteolytic enzymes, especially seropeptidase. So proteolytic enzymes. So enzymes are made by proteins.
They are a protein. They're made by your body, different parts of your body, um, your pancreas makes a lot of your digestive enzymes.
And in the olytic means they break down, lytic breaks down proteins proteins. So a proteolytic enzyme is a, has an enzyme that breaks down proteins.
A lot of enzymes do break down proteins. You do have enzymes that break down fats, those are called light paces.
Um, and you have proteins that break down starches called amulases.
So there's different types of enzymes, but seropeptidase is one of the enzymes that is can be a very anti inflammatory can also help reduce pain and swelling.
It can be very beneficial for the gut. It can be very beneficial for the respiratory tract for bronchitis and chronic lung issues and chronic respiratory and asthma issues.
And even said to be good for blood clots, but lumbarol kinases, a much better enzyme for blood clots, clots and nano kinase.
But seropeptidase is a great enzyme for a lot of things. Of course, I'm very big on all the enzymes. So I really like the different mixed enzymes from US enzymes.
I'm probably one of my favorite enzymes because they are so clean in their production that company is in their enzyme production. So you get a really good quality enzyme.
But they actually make a lot of enzymes for a lot of other nutritional products too. So if you're using an enzyme.
It might actually be made by US enzymes. So, but so seropeptidase is an enzyme that can be beneficial for all those things.
So enzymes can be extremely beneficial. If people think of them as just oh, they'll help me digest my food, but they do more than that. So especially if you take enzymes on an empty stomach, you will absorb more of them. So they'll do less work because there's going to be less work to do in the gut itself.
You'll absorb those enzymes that they have actions systemically. So they can help with your bloodstream. They can help with your tissues.
Dr. William Kelly's enzyme therapy for cancer is taking high doses of enzymes to help to so that you absorb them on an empty stomach. Of course, so you absorb them.
And they help break down the cancer now every single one of our patients has been tested for enzyme therapy if we don't have you on a fairly high dose enzyme that you didn't test for that.
But enzymes, even if you don't test for can be really good for a lot of things. And remember, just because you have cancer, this is what we're testing you for when you were doing the cheek swab and stuff doesn't mean you don't have other conditions to so there can be, you know, a good argument that you should be taking supplements for and different things for other conditions or you should be eating right just like going back to the question about food and
should I be eating meat how much I eat and I heard animal protein is not good for you. Well, some people don't do well on animal protein. They should eat it at all, regardless of whether it feeds their cancer or not. So you do want to treat yourself as systemically and holistically as possible. So there's times to use that one of the one of my favorite supplements that I take every day almost without fail our enzymes.
So they can have a lot of benefits. You know, I'm obviously real big on HCl and digestive enzymes forgot health and digestion, but using the digestive plus from US enzyme.
I believe that has Sarah Pep today said it, but I take personally the lumbarose I'm in the dado kind ace because I'm very susceptible. I don't know if has something to do with my genes or not to
to the spike protein. I don't feel well after I've been around people that have been vaccinated. Sorry, if you've been vaccinated, but
so I'm conscious of this that you're right here. So it's the lumbarokide so the dado kinase are better for that. And if that's due to that term is due to you, I have a blog post. So just search
lumbarokide ace up here and I have a blog post that and you'll be able to see that. So if you just start typing it in, you'll be able to see the blog post if you want to.
Next question. How many hours between the night and day treatments.
I understand when I write these questions down, I'm literally copied and pasted from somebody's email. So I'm assuming that that person is saying
that they're, do they have to, is there a recommended pause between doing my night programs and then should I pause for a period of time between if I do my day programs. The answer is no, I mean, you there, you can literally run the right 24 seven if you want.
But the only time we really recommend that for people is if the person's cancer is growing crazy, we do want you to live your life. So when I was really, when I was at my worst, I was running the right all day at work. And I was running it as soon as I got home in my chair and all night long, I was running the right. So that's how my staff knew I wasn't feeling good.
Because I had my right Friday. So they would go, oh, he's not doing so good today, he's got us right Friday, during the day. So I tend to be a person that doesn't sit down for very long.
When I work at my computer, I obviously do, but I'm a kind of person that goes on vacation and drives his wife crazy because we're going to finally sit out and lay down on the beach and I'll sit down for five minutes and have to get up and walk the beach and listen to him.
I'm not a person because I can't stay up to sit any longer. So, but that's just me. And that makes it hard for me to write when I am what I need to, during the day. So, but there does not have to be any pause between night and day treatments. You can run it 24 seven.
Next is the grounding mat left on the bed at night. So the grounding mat that comes with your wife is specifically for the foot bath for the I am pro wave. That's what it's for. It's not for you to use at night.
If you're talking, if the question that this person is asking, they're not talking about the grounding mat that came with the true right, they're talking about a ground sheet that they bought.
Or a grounding mat at some other distributor or something that they purchased.
Should you have it on your bed at night. So here's my take, I know my good true right has a different philosophy about this, but
This is, this is my thing, my light of thinking. So you're running the right, you're running the frequencies out of this bulb.
The frequencies are going to be attracted to a ground. So if you have a grounding sheet on your bed, my recommendation is that you put the grounding sheet only on the lower part of the bed. So on your but talks down goes the grounding sheet.
And why would you do that? Because you're not, you're holding that right on your chest, you're struggling with it laid on your back. Let's say you roll on your side.
The, the, the right bulb is laid on your mattress. And if you have a grounding sheet there underneath your fitted sheet, you could be losing a lot of the frequencies to the ground.
It's to the grounding sheet out the wire into the machine and of the ground into the ground into the ground.
So you could be losing a lot of the benefits of the frequencies. You want the frequencies to go through your body. Otherwise, they're not doing anything. So it's not helping you. So we, we, that people have asked us that last time. How come you don't sell a grounding sheet with your package. We do have grounding sheets if you want to buy one.
You only use it on the lower half of your bed. I don't want you using a grounding sheet.
While you're right feet, unless you could be very conscious about your bulb placement in a state, you're late. I stay on my back all night long, and I don't even move. So the bulb I wake up, but it's I'm still snuggling with the bulb on my abdomen, then you'd probably be fine with the grounding sheet.
But not everybody is like that. And not everybody stays in one position all night long. So, but if you talk, if this question is addressing the grounding mat that came with your right from us, it should not even be used at night on your bed. It's only used with the foot bath.
And then how many times do you do the foot bath per week? How many times should you do the foot bath per week? Everybody's different. So there, if we programmed some specific cancer program, foot bath programs for you, I would say do that a couple times a week would be good.
So I've told everybody that has asked me because I'm completely upfront and honest with myself, I never do the foot bath. Is that good? No, don't do what I do, do what I say. So I don't do the foot bath because again, I'm too, I just that's just me, I can't sit there and do the foot bath.
So it's, it's, but is it good to do the foot bath? Yes, there's some great benefits to the foot bath. You have this great tool, use the foot bath. How many times we have some patients that do it every day.
Can you do it too many times?
Yeah, you could do anything too many times when it hurts you if you did it five times a day, probably not, but you, you need, you should be living your life not doing your foot bath five times a day.
Doing foot bath once a day is probably really should be your maximum. So that should be only if you're really doing poorly and you're not feeling well, but if you're starting to feel well and stuff you need to start focusing on other things in your life and filling your purpose and not sitting there doing your foot bath, then doing it every couple, a couple times a week is more appropriate.
Next question on that is our last question that was on here. So start chatting into your questions if you have them. Here's one that came in. What is the role of Epsom salt in the liver gall bladder flush.
So Epsom salt in the liver gall bladder flush. So the liver gall bladder flush is another tool to help flush out your gall bladder. It's a liver gall bladder flush. You can see it again on our blog page. There's a mild, which I always recommend people start with that doesn't involve Epsom salt and then there is
more severe gall bladder flush. If you want to say that and that is using Epsom salts, it just helps draw your contraction from the gall bladder to help you're trying to get the greatest contraction of the gall bladder. That's what you're using the Epsom salt with all of oil.
The greatest contraction of the gall bladder. So it squeezes out as many of the stones as possible.
Make sure that isn't the first gall bladder liver gall bladder flush. You do make sure you do the mild ones several times before you get to the Epsom salt.
Any other questions, if you have a question, you can unmute yourself and verbalize your question or you could chat again.
What is the reason for saying that we are not supposed to have bone broth when it also says we're supposed to drink soups?
So it depends on the person. So bone broth. So bone broth is made by boiling bones for a long period of time.
Whether it be chicken bones or beef bones or pork bones, you're boiling it and you're getting the broth from the bones. What you're getting from that is you're getting a very high concentration of glutamine.
Well, that's so bone broth is a really great tool to help heal a person's gut.
So the epithelial cells that line your small and larger intestine feed off of glutamine very powerfully and it really helps them
multiply and grow and heal.
Glutamine can be a very strong driver for growth.
And that's why glutamine is contained in a lot of bone healing supplements. So you see some gut healing GI supplements.
It contains, it can contain anywhere between, you know, a gram to five grams of L glutamine.
And the reason why is it's, it's basically a supplement of, you know, what will you find in bone broth and it can be very effective and help healing the gut.
Well, it heals the gut because it stimulates growth, not just of epithelial cells, but strongly of epithelial cells.
Well, if you have cancer, glutamine, you know, even if your cancer is not driven, if we tested you and you could eat meat, I still do, I still never recommend high glutamine foods or supplements to a person.
So the amount of glutamine you forget enough of a well-made bone broth is pretty high.
So you, that wouldn't be something that you'd want to do. So bone broth is not something that you'd want to do given a cancer diagnosis, even if when we tested you, that meats were okay for you.
So you can still make soup without making a strong bone broth. So I boiled my chicken for a couple hours till it fell off the bone, but then I did take all the bones off of it.
And I left the chicken cut up the chicken and then I added my vegetables and rice or harmony chicken soup. That's not a really strong bone broth.
So when you talk about making a bone broth drink for a person that has serious gut issues, you're talking about boiling the bone broth or leaving it on a simmer for a couple of days in a crock pot to get all the broth out of that bone.
You're getting a very high concentrated glutamine. That's where the same thing is using a supplement for gut healing with a high concentration of glutamine.
So that's the reason why you wouldn't want to do a bone broth with cancer. Maybe a better thing to do is to make a soup.
But instead of boiling the whole chicken or for boiling it for less time, a or number two, using just the chicken meat, if you're making, if chicken is okay for a person to eat, I've said that you're going to make chicken soup and chicken breast and cutting it up and adding just the chicken breast so you're not getting the bone at all.
So then your soup is a very low glutamine soup.
That's the idea. So it's the glutamine content and bone broth.
You can make vegetable broth. That doesn't have glutamine in it. You can make a vegetable soup. I wouldn't have any glutamine in it.
You could make a chicken soup, like I said, with fairly low glutamine, almost, you know, very low glutamine, if you're just using the chicken breast and down a little bit higher, if you boil the chicken carcass for a period of time, hopefully that answers that.
Back to the chat. Castor oil packs. Instruction say stomach areas. Can they be placed on the limb area, such as the armpits chest anywhere that feels good answers. Yes, so you can put castor oil packs anywhere the only place that I would caution you to do it is doing it right over a breast cancer.
You've had patients that do it successfully right over a breast cancer, but go slow on that. So if you're going to, if a person has a breast cancer and you're going to put a castor oil pack over it, don't leave it there for a long period of time, I would just even try five minutes at a time and see.
Well, usually we recommend castor oil packs over the liver. So that's on the right side lower ribs and right underneath the ribs.
If you get that right side over the liver, that could be one of the most beneficial places for castor oil packs is it really helps helps pull helps get the liver moving and will really speed your detoxification pathways.
You can put it over a limb areas, it can help with limb flow to so there's lots of ways that you could use castor oil packs.
Secondly, a lot of people are like, I do another castor oil packs, they're so messy.
Even using hot packs, just using hot water models or using that the
the high the low EMF hot pack that electric hot pack that we have that is infrared is really good over the liver.
So if you don't have time to mess with castor oil packs and you're just putting a hot pack over your liver is, you can have really great benefits too.
But yeah, you can move around, you can do them at different spots, did definitely don't put castor oil in your eye or anything like that.
My doctor recommended that I get my escar biopsy, he said the cancer type might change from zebra to an elephant is that true.
Can cancer change types after you've already been diagnosed.
I know, I don't know, I don't think so, no.
So the type of cancer cancer is named by the cell type that is involved in the tumor itself.
So, and really, that's really not going to change how you're treating it anyhow.
Yes, maybe if you were going to do chemotherapy, possibly, I just don't see that being at all an issue, no.
Why would you do that? I just know I don't see that I had to really talk to that doctor to see what his thought processes, but because I'm not jiving with that and I could be wrong, but I just don't get what he's thinking about there.
This is the growth concerned with broth, also a reason for not fasting more than 48 hours. Yes, but it's a different, it's a different chemical process.
So the fasting for 48 hours after you fast for more than 48 24 hours, sorry, after you fast for more 24 hours, your idea of one level score.
Yeah, it probably does stimulate IGF1 pathways. So yes, they are tied together somewhat metabolically.
But yes, it's the exact same process that we're talking about here exactly right.
No matter how well it makes you feel to do that because of growth, yes, that's exactly right.
So if you don't have cancer fasting more than 24 hours, again, you should work up through fasting processes, but fasting more than 24 hours can be very beneficial because it increases IGF1.
And IGF1 can be really good for anti-aging, can be really good for cell regeneration because it increases growth of cells.
And hey, it's great to have new cell growth, but you certainly don't want IGF1 port on the cancer because it's going to increase cell growth.
So understand how that is. So things that you would do, this is the heart that you functional medicine. So things that you would do that would be really good for your heart are not necessarily really good for cancer.
So I want to increase my veg F production because it'll increase vascular endothelial growth factor growth of new vessels in my heart.
That's going to be really good for that. So I'm going to use high dietary oxide supplements and things like that and different anti-aging things like that that are really good for your heart.
So you don't want to do that for cancer. So you don't want to increase event Jeff, you do not want to increase IGF1, you do not want to increase vascularization when you have cancer.
So some of the things that you would do if you didn't have cancer for, for to help you, you know, live longer to support vascular function, different things, these things that you wouldn't do with cancer, so you got to be aware of that.
That's a question. Dr. Cutters, what is your opinion on quintons marine plasma and folic acid? I am reading the Bible and I'll turn it a bit of said.
And the doctor who wrote the book highly recommends these they can be really good. I know that the quintons marine plasma liquid that is known that quick silver carries some.
We have we have some in our store doesn't it has never tested right and we have had it for years when they first came up with it. It's never tested for people for cancer. It's nothing wrong with it. I think it can be good for different things, but it's never tested as a cancer treatment.
Literally never. So we've had people buy it. I don't even think we have it in stock right now, but.
We've had people buy it because they read something about it or their doctor recommended some of their doctor recommended it.
And I'm sure there's some real good benefits to help balance your your electrolytes and such. So I think there's can be really good balance benefits of it, but it's for cancer.
For some reason, I was really excited about it. We first got it.
Six or seven years ago, but it's just never tested.
The folic acid is totally different story. So folic acid is is a fantastic binder.
We have it a lot of products. So folic and cubic acid are great products. They can be binders that actually you can absorb.
They can really help with mold. They can help bind heavy metals. They're just they're great things.
They're proven to test really well.
There are a lot of different things that we use.
Is bovine gelatin similar to bone broth. Yes, it is.
So my gelatin has.
Has a glutamine in it, but it's in fairly low concentration. So if there's a bovine gelatin in one of your capsules of supplements, there's not enough even measurable glutamine in it.
But if you're using bovine gelatin in a food, I don't I don't know the concentration if you're using it in a recipe or something like that.
So I don't think it's a major concern because I think you have to consume a lot to get the glutamine out of it. So next, there are some right programs that said to use the grounding mat on the back or under the foot.
Yes, okay. For example, the ones for back pain. So you can wisely use the grounding mat. We used to actually sell the rights with this grounding. There's on the front of your machine. I think on the F122's that still has it has a grounding plug that you could plug in a grounding wand.
We used to sell a grounding wand with the rights to you. Then you could strategically place the wand somewhere really only worked for like rectal cancer. So if you put the bulb on your abdominal cavity and you put the wand between your cheeks.
You could effectively kind of draw the frequencies through the body to that that wand. And you can, if you really think about it, use a grounding sheet and or a grounding pad wisely to basically direct the frequencies towards something.
But then you have to be very conscious of that. So let's say I have breast cancer. Could you put the bulb right over your breasts and put the grounding mat behind your back and then lead back.
Yes, you could, but then you got to understand to just because you have breast cancer doesn't mean you don't have circulating tumor cells in your liver or in your brain.
You don't want to have metastasis to those areas. So that's why I caution you about using the grounding mat or grounding sheet or grounding wand where you're using your cancer programs that we have written for you because you want them to go
and disperse as evenly as possible throughout your whole body. You don't want them to necessarily be directed through your body and then out to a grounding pencil where
so yes, if you're running different specific frequencies for back pain, you can do that. That makes sense. You're putting the pad behind your back and you want the frequencies to go right through there, right to that area. That makes that makes perfect sense.
And that could be a good thing, but I would caution you about use. You have to be very wise with your use of those things when you're running your your cancer programs.
Okay.
Good.
Any other questions.
So, um, and we got a bunch of people on, um, I do want to make an adult spend to everybody is that we are moving our clinic.
So anybody that's been to our clinic, you're like, what your moving yes, our lease is due and we've been looking forward to the state of our move for a long period of time.
Well, so we'll have a different Bailey to address. So make sure you call in and ask for the Bailey to address if you're Bailey to cheek swab to us. Now, we won't have an issue with getting it.
We actually have this space and have our mailbox through August.
But we had this wonderful opportunity to get in this other space and we're excited to get into this other space.
So, um, if you do mail it to this current address, we'll still get it. We'll be checking our mail daily, but we'll be telling you to mail any bulk packages or anything else to our new address.
So that I will be sitting outside or door.
So make sure you call the clinic to get that new address. If you have to mail anything to us.
And that will be the nice benefit of getting our membership only pages done so that we will be able to put up announcements like that on our membership only pages and speak about that.
I said at the beginning of this that we hope to have that it's, I really have them almost completely done, but we're waiting on the HubSpot to get it fully published.
I hope it by next week or the week after for sure we're going to have that up and running.
Everybody is going to get a bulk email from us. So you will get an email from us on how to log into that. So you'll have a link to get to that membership site that isn't going to be public though other people could probably find it.
If they searched for something like that, but it will be a login only site. So you'll use your primary email or the one that we will email to you.
And you will then create your own password, just like any other site and its password protected. And if you forget your password, there'll be a forgot your password button so that you can, you could create a new password.
So about in there, there'll be a whole bunch of videos all the zoom calls like this will be on there. So that you can access them at a later date if you so desired and a bunch of different patient only things that you can access.
And since it's like the, the, the through binder that was said to you people that got a binder two years ago, it looks different today because we updated things and change things we changed the protocols things in life happened.
If things in society happened that we had to change the big different protocols for different things. So they'll, they'll will be anytime we update the binder the updated binder will be there. And I'm talking about the pages that are specific to you, of course, like your diet specific to you, but the other pages.
I also want to recommend that if you haven't seen already there, and I know everybody's information overload already so probably shouldn't say this, but my book on the seven phases of detox is available as a download for you on our website.
If you want to look at that go back to our website look at books and this is the book. It's called the seven phases of detoxification. It's not that long. It's less than a hundred pages and it's you could go through it and say easy read, but it talks about the reason why we do some of the make some of the recommendations that we make that will help you understand the physiology and some of the reasons why.
So that could be a good book in my book on mushrooms. I finished as well. We're just yeah that's at the editors that hopefully will be up in the next couple months too. So my book on medicinal mushrooms. So all right. Well, no other questions. We will say good night for tonight. I will probably do next week's zoom calls well because I made
She'll do a couple of a row there when I was called last week. So I'll be praying for you. We cherish your prayers for us as well. And if you need any further assistance, make sure you call and set it up with the point with myself or Michelle as well. All right. I'll be well. Bye bye.
So I think what you said. Yeah, sorry.